director of the institute welcome to the
boot camp
for the program satisfiability theory
practice and beyond
it's one of two programs that we're
running this semester the other is
theoretical foundations of computer
systems
and together they're involving around
120 long-term participants
at the institute for those of you that
weren't here for last week's
boot camp the boot camps intended to get
all of the program participants on the
same page
in terms of the range of technical
themes in in the program
also has a significant archival value um
as a sort of snapshot of a state of the
art of the field
the talks are archived on on youtube
and on our website uh let me introduce
jesse gill our events coordinator
who's here yeah hey jesse um
jesse has been dealing with the the
schedule and logistics for the boot camp
here at the summers institute so big big
thank you to jesse
uh and and a big thank you to the
organizers of the boot camp albert at
sirius
uh sam bus vijay ganesh antonina
kolakolova
and jacob nordstrom for putting together
the program for this week
so thanks very much for all of your uh
efforts
so i'll hand over to albert to say a few
words about boot camp
thank you very much peter so welcome
everybody to the first day of the
bootcamp
workshop for the satisfiability program
and as most of you know the bootcamps
were supposed to be
full day events that would happen in
berkeley itself
and would run for a whole week but of
course because of the pandemic
we cannot do it this way so instead what
we are going to do is
that we ask the speakers to prepare
pre-recorded lectures that they will
that they have posted already on
the website and so there will be a
pre-recorded component
and a live component and today we are
going to start with the live component
so the idea would be that experts would
be able to hear the talks today without
any preparation
but those who really need the tutorial
then the pre-recorded component
is serves that purpose still today is
still a tutorial style kind of uh
of talk that's how it's expected to be
so i want to start by thanking uh all
the speakers of the bootcamp for the
huge amount of work that they have put
into preparing
pre-recorded talks it's a lot of work
it's many hours of of recording and
it's very good quality work so thank you
very much for
for your efforts so today we'll start
with the first
the first so there are five days of boot
camp
and four of them are going to be
tutorials delivered by a single
speaker and on friday we're going to
have what we call
applications so and friday is going to
be a slightly different we're going to
have
three two speakers
and they're going to give 50 minute
lectures but on monday tuesday wednesday
and thursday we have
distinguished lecturers who are going to
tell us about
specific areas within satisfiability
and today we are going to start with
valentine cabinets who
is going to tell us about complexity
theory centered around set
so valentine is a professor at the
algorithms and complexity theory lab
at the simon's simon fraser university
in canada
and he's a well-known expert in
complexity theory
and he has done very amazing work so let
me
tell you a little bit about his work in
2001 he obtained his phd from
steve cook and the thesis was titled
non-uniformly hard boolean functions and
uniform complexity classes
so the working hysteresis included
pioneering work
on the minimum circuit size problem
which is today
a central theme in complexity theory for
its relevance for
things like magnification and other
very important trends in complexity
theory these days
but this was in his thesis but also very
early work of his
perhaps also in the thesis or at least
around
his early times he
he did some work with russell pagliato
and navi victorson
with which included what is today called
the easy witness lemma and this is a
very important
theorem in complexity theory which is
also a central theme today
in what is known as the meta
algorithms approach to circuit lower
bounds
where algorithms for satisfiability play
a very important role
so valentine did very pioneering work
and these
these two areas and and it's really
important work
and i'm very happy that today he's going
to tell us about
uh about complexity theory
centered around sad so let's get ready
to to enjoy his life lecture
i think he calls it dancing with sad
so valentine over to you thank you very
much
albert for the nice introduction i want
this guy to give a talk that you talked
about
um so let's see if that works
so can you see my shared screen
perfectly well excellent so
good morning good berkeley morning
everybody
uh whatever time zone you're in
so this is live part of the south center
complexity tutorial
and the unofficial title is dancing
around sat
because basically that's what we're
doing in complexity we're trying to
understand
uh what sat is how easy how hard it is
and its connections to pretty much every
other corner
of complexity theory and we just
exploring and will keep exploring
probably for a long time
um so sat has lots of connections to
many things um in particular to
and the completeness of course that's
the main thing that is
known for but also polymer time
hierarchy
probabilistically checkable proofs
interactive proofs and so forth
and that's some of the things that i
talked about
in the pre-recorded part of the tutorial
which has some background information
today's
tutorial will not be really building on
top of this
prerecorded stuff from earlier so for
people who haven't watched it
it's fine um it will be fine you'll be
okay
um and i'll talk about some other things
that um i left for the live part of the
tutorial
uh complexity of sad like exponential
time complexity hypothesis
and related stuff and some connections
to circuit lower bounds
and we'll see if i have any time left
about to talk about some something else
so talking about sat
uh let's uh remember what we're talking
about threesat
is the famous problem uh given uh three
cnf
like this one here is it satisfiable or
not
and later on we'll talk about k south so
this is just
the formula where each clause is of size
k
or at most k and usually we think of k
as a constant
we know from cook levin's theorem from
50 years ago
that this problem three start is very
difficult
it captures the complexity of a whole
bunch of problems in the class
and p it's one of the and the complete
problems so we know for sure that if you
can solve
free satisfiability in polynomial time
then you've done great work
you solve pretty much every problem in
np in polynomial not pretty much but
every problem in np is solved
in polynomial time as well um
well there are still papers being
written about uh saudi and polynomial
time
um we far from
getting there or even believing that
this is actually possible
and it's still a million dollar question
uh to figure out
the exact complexity of free
satisfiability
so there are options of how complex this
problem can be
um so here's a
graph of possibilities uh so on the left
side you have polynomial time complexity
for
k sat and here will be usual
measure of complexity uh it will be the
number of variables in a given formula
so we want to solve um invariant k sub
problems in time
um polynomial n or something some other
non-trivial function and then
so polynomial then polymer time is
probably out of the question
so this is like the the most optimistic
scenario
um but there are other possibilities
even if p is different from np it could
be that sat can be solved say
in quasi-polynomial time like n to the
power poly login
that would be quite good um if that's
not true
we can move on and say okay how about
sub-exponential time like
to then to the epsilon for every epsilon
not as good as quasi-polynomial but
still quite non-trivial
we're not there anywhere near uh so how
about
slightly better than exponential like
too little of n to the epsilon n for any
epsilon
we're still not there and what we do
know
for all versions of sat is how to solve
it in brute force
which of course take time to the end
times a polynomial factor
by trying all possible assignments to
formulas
and so we can do here and we don't
believe
polynomial time and you know
it seems like at the moment we're
working somewhere around
this regime of complexity of sat
and rather than assuming that sat is not
in polynomial time
it may be worthwhile to consider a
hypothesis that sat requires exponential
time
like to the omega n and see what happens
maybe we can just prove it maybe we can
have some other connections
so it's a fact or it's a theorem
proved by many people from different
directions
and i hope to talk about it a bit later
today what's what we know about
algorithms for k sat
well basically we know something
non-trivial
we know that k sub can be solved in a
randomized
column a randomized time which is
exponential but exponential not
just in n but exponential in n times
some quantity like 1 minus 1 over k
if you think of k as a constant then 1
minus 1 over k's
is a constant less than 1. so this gives
you time
better than to the n okay with some a
multiplicative
constant an exponent there and
different directions different
algorithmic approaches starting from
late 80s
and happening until now and still
happening
achieve pretty much the same bound this
constant
here which i denote as one is actually
some constant c
depending on the algorithm it may be
different c but i'm gonna ignore that
for now
just a constant and i'll i'll hope to
give you one such algorithm a bit later
but the point is that we don't have
very fast algorithm for ksat so let's
formulate
this hypothesis saying that you know you
cannot
solve case satisfiability in
sub-exponential time
and that's exactly what uh uh rasulallah
said
in around 1999 and let's they formulated
this
so-called exponential time hypothesis
which said what i said
said free satisfiability cannot be
solved
in time to the little or of n
and some polynomial uh factor
and it's a hypothesis because as russia
likes to say
the hypothesis rather the conjecture
meaning that
whichever way you answer would be very
interesting
okay so if it's true if exponential time
hypothesis is true
this is the left branch of the answer
then we know that p is different from np
and much more
uh we have much stronger bound than just
uh aside as difficult
for polynomial time and if the
hypothesis is false
that's fantastic you have some very
non-trivial algorithm for solving k
sat and such an algorithm must have come
with some interesting techniques some
structural properties about sat
that may be pushed even further and get
even better algorithms
and not only do we have an algorithm for
k sat not trivia algorithm for cassette
but also for other problems and i will
talk about this connection
to other problems later on we'll talk
about so-called specification lemma
but first let's think about this
excuse me sequence of problems like 3
sat 4
sat 5 sat and so forth it seems like
as k increases your problem
k sat should get harder intuitively
speaking
is it getting strictly harder as k grows
um we cannot answer unconditionally but
assuming that sat cannot be done in
sub-exponential time
the answer is indeed yes as k grows
k star gets harder and harder strictly
harder and harder
and that's one of the result proved by
mohan and russell
in the same paper where they talked
about
exponential time hypothesis
[Music]
so it seems like
uh k start getting harder and harder and
as k gets bigger the running time that
you need for solving k sub approaches
more more and more closely uh the
trivial brute force runtime of to the n
is it really true it seems so okay
so let's formulate that as another
hypothesis
why not we cannot solve sat
with for large k significantly better
than to the end so let's call it strong
exponential time hypothesis
again introduced by russell and mohan
with a student
calabro in around 2009
and it says that no matter how
small epsilon you choose to get trying
to get to the time
to the n times one minus epsilon
for whatever small epsilon you choose
there will be a large enough constant k
such that k sat cannot be solved
in this running time to the one minus
epsilon times n
okay so even getting close enough to to
the end but be below to the end is very
difficult and some large k sat
for large k will show you that that's
not possible
so that's the strong exponential time
hypothesis
and again it's a hypothesis so there are
interesting
implications uh each way
so if the hypothesis is false
then you have of course a somewhat
non-trivial algorithm for k-stat
and other problems let me focus
more on the direction if the hypothesis
is true
so if it's true then um you basically
say that
you're basically saying that the brute
force lower bound
the brute force algorithm for sat which
takes time to the end
is basically optimal you cannot improve
upon that
so brute force is optimal for and not
only for
4k sat for which the hypothesis is
formulated but it was noted and proved
by many people
that other mp complete problems have the
same
behavior brute force algorithms for
those
is optimal so you cannot improve upon
the trivial to the end time
for those problems where it's a
non-trivial time
and there's this whole area of research
dedicated to studying the exact
exponential time complexity of such np
complete or nd heart problems
called exact exponential time algorithms
and they use strong exponential time
hypothesis
to argue the optimality of for many of
their
exact exponential time algorithms
but it's not only true for exponential
time algorithms
actually this hypothesis strongly th is
so strong that it can be kind of
trans translated down to the level of
polynomial time and you can prove some
highly non-trivial results about the
optimality of
even polynomial time algorithms
and for example you can show things like
assuming strong a th
your basic algorithms course
algorithm for edit distance which takes
quadratic time
is actually optimal and this
area of uh complexity theory also has a
name
it's called fine grain complexity theory
uh pioneer by
uh celeskia williams and ryan williams
and
lots of other peoples have contributed
in this active area of research
currently
and you know there are some amazing
results saying that you know these
algorithms
like quadratic time algorithms for
example that people have discovered for
a long time now and
and we're working very hard to try to
improve actually cannot be significantly
improved
unless you also violate the stronger th
so unless you get a better algorithm for
satisfiability so
working on edit distance is the same as
working on satisfiability can you can't
get away from satisfiability
you have to keep dancing around that
but you tell me you you know we don't
know any such good k-state algorithm
um um that to talk about even
time like um uh to the end um
better than to the end so what we do
know what i mentioned to you and what i
will hope
to hoping to show you later today is
that all
knowns k-set algorithms take time
um to the power n times
1 minus 1 over k or one minus ck for
some constant
c and we don't have anything better even
though we try different ways
um can we solve k sat an actual question
can we solve k sat
in better time than this so can we
improve
this uh bound 1 minus 1 over k
to something which mentions maybe some
small growing function of k
like log k over k or log star
k over k anything non-trivial growing
super constant growing function we don't
know how to do it
okay so why not formulate that as a
another exponential time hypothesis and
that's what
ryan williams did actually giving a talk
at simon's
that was dedicated to fine-grained
complexity and exact uh
algorithms exponential time algorithms a
few years back
he termed this uh super strong eth super
strong ath super strong exponential time
hypothesis
which basically says that you cannot
beat
to the n times one minus one over k run
time for k
sat okay this is like getting very
fine-grained and very crazy
uh saying that you know whatever we know
for kisat right now
is the best and i think it's like the
purpose of this
statement is more to encourage people to
work harder and try to get a better
algorithm for ksat
and even for unique case sat
so a couple years ago ryan with a
student vyas proved that this
super strong eth is false for the case
of random k-sat
so the classical algorithm uh judo
pattoripola kansai and ppc algorithm
actually works quite well on random
k-star formula sampled
near the threshold of satisfiability and
achieves time
uh to the power n 1 minus
log k over k so you can get log k over k
savings for random case for general case
we don't know how to get any better
saying that what
constant over k gives us um but another
interesting observation
non-trivial result uh in um
ryan's and gases paper is that
if you want to understand the complexity
of k-site algorithms
without loss of generality you can focus
on the case of unique case sat
and this is the case of case out where
you're given a formula kcnf and you
promised that the formula is
either unsatisfiable or it's satisfied
by exactly one
truth assignment so it has a unique
satisfying assignment
and the case of unique side is actually
very interesting special case that
people like to consider and it's often
the first test case for
uh analyzing proposed
k-stat algorithms it's usually easier to
analyze
the performance of a given k-state
algorithm for the case of unique case
sat
and as far as this super strong eta is
concerned
to break that it's enough to improve a
unique k-set algorithm beyond what we
currently know
so if you get a better than to the power
n times one minus one over k
algorithm for unique case out then
you're done for general k sat as well
so there's a very nice sub-exponential
time reduction in
that paper and we can actually probably
start a new page of like complexity zoo
for
exponential time hypothesis because
there's there are more
uh there was another so-called
non-deterministic strong eth that was
proposed by
russell mohan and a few of their
students
in 2016 non-activistic
strong eth i'm not going to talk about
that now
what i want to talk about is very
important tool
which is uh heavily used in many of
these results around
h and strongly th called sparsification
lemma and this is the result from the
paper by
uh the paglets of paturin zane around
1998 and that's what i would like to
talk about next
of course if there are any questions at
any point in time please
ask chat them uh and i'm
monitoring the chat feeds on chat and
questions and answers so please don't be
shy if there is anything
that i need to specify more precisely
so roughly speaking the specification
lemma says that
the hardest k sat instances are those
which have linear number of clauses okay
so given a case c and f you as usual
it's
n variables and we'll use m to denote
the number of clauses in the k
c and f and a priori if you have a k
c and f then the number of clauses can
be as big as
n to the k so you can have polynomially
many clauses in general
but it turns out that the linear case
where the number of clauses is just some
constant times
n is the hardest one with respect to
sub-exponential time algorithms like to
the level of end-time algorithms
uh so the j is asking about the number
of variables number of clauses
yeah so i'm i'm addressing this question
right now talking about specification
lemma
so yeah many of these results and i'll
hope to show you an application of
specification lemma
allows you to prove that
exponential time hypothesis rules out
fast algorithms not just for k sat
which hypothesis is formulated for but
also for some other problems
that you get by reductions but
reductions have to be very special
um and yes preserving um
keeping the number of clauses linear the
number of variables is crucial
you shall see hopefully in a moment an
application of this
so classification number basically says
that you know you might as well focus
develop your best algorithms for k sat
for the case of uh
linear number of clauses in number of
variables constant ratio
between clauses and variables as a
corollary
um you get the following result which
it ties in nicely with what vijay was
asking me i think
so fix any constant k bigger than or
equal to three
y at least three because three side is
empty complete
and anything bigger than three is going
to be complete
then you have the following implication
if you can solve k sat in
sub-exponential time where the
input parameter is thought of as the sum
of the number of variables and the
number of clauses
so if you have an algorithm which runs
in time to the little log of
the number of clauses plus the number of
variables
then you also get a case at algorithm
with running time too little of n where
n is just a number of variables
so if somehow magically mysteriously
you manage to get a fast algorithm which
takes advantage of the number of clauses
and runs in time too little or of m
then you can always unwind this magic
and make an algorithm for k-stat that
will run in time
to little of n for the number of
variables n and too little of n is
really what we want to get because
through the end we can always we can
always get
uh too little of n is going to be very
surprising and
it this reduction kind of causes this
strange
possibilities that you can have an
algorithm that runs in too little of
number of clauses
but maybe not no algorithm that runs
into a little of number of variables
that would be very strange and uh
specification lama says no that's not
gonna happen
we can always do this reduction so
assuming this reduction here
uh here's what you do to prove that some
other problems in
np anti-complete problems are also
exponentially hard
here's an application there's a
classical
np completeness reduction that you will
probably see
in any class on algorithms or complexity
and teach to your students
saying that you can reduce through
satisfiability to three coloring
um fixed sensibility you know three
coloring is a problem we're given a
graph and you
want to know if it's possible to color
the notes of the graph using three
colors
rgb such that no edge gets the same
color on its end points
very famous very well known and p
complete problem there's a standard
classical reduction
that takes a cnf free cnf
formula phi on n variables and m clauses
and in polynomial time reduces it to the
graph
g um on vertices v and edges e
such that the number of vertices is
going to be
constant times the number of variables
plus the number of clauses in a
in an input 3cnf
and the reduction satisfies the
statistability preserving condition that
says that fire satisfiable if and only
if the graph g constructed as a result
of the reduction
is three colorable okay so why do we do
this reductions
we want to say well if you can have a
good algorithm for free colorability if
you have polynomial time algorithm for
three colorability
then you also get a polynomial time for
three sat so that's what you get
immediately from the
anti-completeness reduction classical
reduction
like i described but what if
you only get slightly better than
exponential time algorithm for three
colorability
and in fact you can get something
non-trivial for three color ability
better than to the end time to the to
the time end
so you can do to the power some small
constant
less than one times n so you can beat to
the end time
perfect colorability how far can you
push it down
can you make an algorithm for three
colorability that runs in time to the
little law
of the number of vertices in the graph
what would prevent you from doing so
turns out exponential time hypothesis
will prevent you from doing so
if you can get a running time for
tricolor ability
too little of the number of vertices
then by this corollary i just
described earlier you get that freesat
is solved in time
too little of n as well and that of
course violates the exponential sign
hypothesis
so let's see why it's very simple
suppose i start freeze with algorithm
for recolorability that runs in time to
little
of the number of nodes then
then by the classical reduction uh
that i mentioned earlier you get that
freesat is solvable in time
to the little law of the number of
vertices when you do the translation
from threesat to
recolorability becomes n plus m
so little of the number of vertices
becomes little of the
n plus m okay um
and then unfortunately we have
specification result which says that
okay if you have
too little of n plus m algorithm then
you get a little
of an algorithm as a result and that
violates expansion line hypothesis is
done
so the conclusion is that under eth not
only
you cannot do threesat in subexponential
time
but you cannot do a fake colorability
and
quite a few other important
anti-complete problems in
better than exponential time you cannot
make them sub exponential time
complexity
okay so this is just one one
illustration
uh for one problem but it's a more
general phenomenon
uh the talk that russell and
mohan talked already in the original
paper and there was much more work done
later afterwards
okay so how do you do this um
reduction from uh solving satisfiability
for an arbitrary kc and f
to solving to just needing to solve k
satisfiability for
k c and f within with a linear number of
clauses only
that's exactly what specification lemma
tells you how to do
so let's let me formulate specification
lemma
fix any k at least three then
basically for whatever epsilon you want
there will be some constant c
such that you can constructively
um build from a given input k c and f
phi
on n variables with whatever number of
clauses
a list of k c and f's psi 1
to psi t where t is going to be
sub exponentially small like 2 to the
little of n to the epsilon n
such that your original uh cnf is
satisfiable if and only if
one of this psi 1 psi 2 psi t is
satisfiable
actually it's even more than that the
original uh cnf5 will be exactly equal
logically equivalent
to the disjunction of this new kcnf
psi1 through psi t so all the satisfying
assignments are preserved
and to check satisfiability of phi
you're going to check satisfiability of
which one of the psi eyes
and each one of the psi eyes will be
kcnf on
linear number of clauses okay so you
take your formula you specify it
but you cannot output just one you have
to output a whole bunch of formulas
sparse
c and f's formulas but fortunately not
too many
only like to the epsilon n
and this is constructive constructive in
that you there's an algorithm that i'm
going to show you in a moment
that will spit out this formula ones
to say t in time proportional to the
number of such formulas
polynomial to the epsilon n
so this is the statement
let me explain the algorithm the
algorithm is very simple the analysis is
not very complicated either
although i'm not going to do the
analysis today but
i want you i want to show you the
algorithm so let's call the algorithm
sparsify
it it takes this input formula phi and
outputs
a list of sub-exponentially many uh
sparse
k c and f's so input is a k c and f phi
on n variables
and we think of
clauses given as a list of clauses like
so
um and the first thing you do and you'll
do it
it's also recursively is you'll use this
close assumption rule
which says that if you have two clauses
but one of them
is contained entirely in the other one
then you might as well drop the longer
one
and keep the short one close only in
this case
in this example you have clause not x3
or x5
and then you have clause not x3 or x5 or
x7
this one is bigger so we can subsume it
away
and remove this clause and so we have
fewer clauses
and now we think of our clauses as sets
and we can draw them like sets of
literals like this
and then uh so the first step of the
algorithm is
do close assumption eliminate
unnecessary clauses to simplify the
formula
and the second one is find a sunflower
go pick flowers so what is a sunflower
in this case
you try to collect together
a large constant number of clauses of
the same size
so that they all have a shared part
so they have all have some common part
um
which is called the heart of the
sunflower
so it's an intersection of all the
clauses
hopefully not empty and you want to make
it as big as possible
and the rest each clause without the
heart
is called a paddle okay and so you want
to find a sunflower
which means you want to have a large
number of clauses c1 through c
lambda such that they have a large
intersection and
there are many of them okay so i'm not
specifying the details of the algorithm
but basically the algorithm focuses on
the case of
you even if your formula has closest of
different sizes
you only look at formulas at closest of
the same size when you're looking for a
sunflower like this
and you also favor short clauses so you
try to form a sunflower
from the short clauses first like
closest of size 2 for example
and also when you have larger clauses
that you try to build a sunflower from
you favor large hearts so you want to
find the largest possible intersection
first
with enough clauses and if you cannot do
that then you
lower your expectations and you try to
find a sunflower with smaller hearts
smaller center
and you try to do that until you
verify that you until you find a
sunflower or you verify that there is
none
and if there is none if no sunflower can
be found then you say i'm done
output fine hold and this case is it's
not hard to
see why you stop
if you stop in this way then you know
that your formula is already sparse
and this is a very simple application of
the pigeonhole principle
okay so if there's some variable which
appears
in a large constant number of clauses
then this variable or this literal
rather
will be a heart non-trivial heart over
large sunflower
okay so the only way for you to stop
this algorithm is that
each literal appears in constant number
of clauses only in small constant number
of clauses only
and that means that the number of
clauses itself is also
only linear in the number of variables
okay
so when you stop you get a sparse
formula that's easy to see uh
the petals uh shouldn't be disjoint yes
um so this is it's a it's a weak
sunflower
rather than a strong sunflower um i
didn't want to
make this distinction in the description
of the algorithm so usually when
condensators people define a sunflower
that pairwise intersections are the same
for different sets
for different pairs of sets here you can
have a clause like in my picture
c1 and c2 they also share a variable x1
which doesn't make it into the heart but
yeah petals are not disjoint
even outside the heart don't have to be
yeah we're not using in the analysis
here we're not using anything
uh super complicated about like
sunflowers
that mathematicians study it's much
simpler argument like original principle
based basically
so what happens if you did find a
sunflower then you do the split
and recurse so you take your formula phi
and you form two sub formulas phi one
and phi two
by plucking your sunflower and putting
the heart on the one side
and putting the petals on the other side
okay
and of course by subsumption rule uh the
heart will kick out all the clauses that
contributed to the heart
in the next recursive iteration and the
petals will kick out all the clauses
that they came from so in the first
case you make definite progress because
you
kicked out a whole bunch of clauses and
replaced them with a single
heart close so that's obvious progress
in the second case you have not reduced
the number of
clauses per se because you know pedals
are still there
but each pedal is now shorter than it
was before
so then the close it was before so
making progress by reducing the size
of the clause even though you don't make
the number of clauses smaller
necessarily
and once you build these two formulas
you recurse and you specify phi one
output the list that you get this way
and then specify phi 2
i'll put the list you get there put
these two lists together and you'll get
your final
list of sparse formulas as a result okay
so that's the algorithm hopefully the
algorithm is clear
the analysis of the algorithm as i
mentioned is not very complicated but
somewhat technical so you need to
analyze this backtracking procedure and
keep track of the progress you make and
there's a bit of complication because
the progress in the
pedal case is not obvious but it's
possible to analyze this case and say
that
if you think about your algorithm as
kind of backtracking procedure and you
have different branches
then the total size of this
binary tree will be at most to the
epsilon n
if you pick your constants right so
basically
you cannot add too many uh clauses to
your formula
on any single branch and
that shows you that the number of the
size of the branching on the size of
this tree
will be better than trivial to the end
size but
rather to the epsilon and size okay so
there's a bit of savings that you can do
by carefully choosing your parameters
like this constant lambda that i
mentioned here
actually it's not a single constant
lambda but it also depends on the
size of clause that you're considering
now so you have a whole sequence of
constants lambda
depending on the size of the clause c
if it's closest of with three then you
have one constant closest or with four
you have different constant
uh properly defined as a sequence and
yeah
it's a careful careful balancing act to
analyze this algorithm
which i'm not gonna do now
okay any questions so far
um okay great
so i'm actually
or somebody has a question that they
don't understand enough
it's just a statement so um
sorry can you be specific
can you ask a specific question what is
not clear
[Music]
i'm actually going much faster than i
thought i would so
it's good that people stop me and ask
questions
okay
good
so that was specification lemma and
exponential time hypothesis related
stuff
um and the next thing i'm going to
do uh is to talk about
this non-trivial casa algorithms
and maybe i'll introduce this
thing now and then we'll take a short
break
because it's like a separate part of my
talk it would be nice to have a
separation between the two
but what we're going to do after the
break assuming that the chair
albert agrees and we're taking a break
of course yes perfect
thank you what we're going to do after
the break is talk about this algorithm
for k sat
and let me just tell you this story now
so i mentioned that we have non-trivial
running time algorithm for k sat
where it runs in time exponential in to
the n
to the power 1 minus 1 over k
where k is the width of the clauses
and interestingly there are different
ways you can try to
get an algorithm for k sat and even
though they kind of look different they
all converge on the same runtime at the
end
so i just mentioned a few of those
threats
backtracking thread which are famous
algorithms ppz that i
we mentioned earlier zane and then there
is a beefed up version of that
paturi pudlax oxen zain algorithm ppsz
the constant over 1 over k here gets
better
but it's still some constant and the
running time is
what is shown then there's a wonderful
algorithm using some kind of randomized
local search due to ubershoning
from around 1999 a very different idea
from or
supposedly different idea from this
backtracking algorithms
of ppc and pplz still the same runtime
roughly again constants change and then
you're using some circuit complexity
ideas
shannon williams in 2016 uh use the
polynomial method that
which is a circuit lower bound technique
that we love and use in
proving uh lower bounds for constant
depth circuits
in complexity theory so you can use turn
this around
and use the circuit lower bound proof
techniques to get algorithms
and you also get the same runtime so
like no matter what you do what we know
and try different
things that we know about ksat you end
up in the same place
which leads some people to suspect maybe
that's the right place
or at least as in in the case of super
strong eth
that leads people to say okay let's
formulate this as a challenge as a
question as a hypothesis
and try to work even harder to disprove
that
so what i'm going to do after the break
is show you
the another algorithm for k sat which
won't
only be an algorithm for checking
satisfiability of a given kcnf
but we'll do more for the same price it
will count the number of satisfying
assignments
in the same runtime that i mentioned to
the power n times 1 minus 1 over k
okay and we'll use so-called switching
lemma
that will be the main tool that i want
to talk about
which is a tool kind of similar to the
polynomial method that people love and
use to proof surrogate lower bounds for
constant depth circuits
known as ac 0 circuits and this
tool that was this basically an
algorithmic tool
can also be turned around and used to
prove
uh to analyze the algorithms to analyze
case hat algorithms
and that's the algorithm the algorithm
from the switching lemma for sharp
keystone is from the
paper by impagazo matthews and paterio
from around 2012
and so i'm going to tell you tell you
all about it or
a lot about it after the break
okay so we're taking the break now yeah
all right
so let's then resume at uh 1860 i'm
sorry
so let's resume in five minutes let's
say that five minutes okay
great thank you
so one thing i wanted to say is i'm not
seeing all the questions for some reason
do i have all the rights to see because
the only questions i see were the ones
in the chat
um that was the only channel that was
was posting something on the question
and answer
channel i don't see anything you
mentioned the question by vijay
and i don't see that yeah that was on
the chat that was on the zoom chat
maybe it was directly to valentin or
something
oh maybe it was downstairs yeah that's
right yes
from vijay it was directly to me direct
messaging okay and also
from pavel also direct to me yeah so
that's why you didn't see those
questions
okay those direct questions to me
yes i don't try to spam everybody with
questions no but don't be shy because
others may also want to ask the same
question but are very shy so
lead the way paul please i just want to
ask one thing so
you have this one minus one over k in
the exponent
but this algorith differ uh in that
in the numerator it's not one but it's
uh some constant
that's right that's right yes it will be
some constant
saying in instance but
you are going to talk about it probably
yeah i'm going to talk about a
particular constant that we'll get from
the switching lemma
and will not be as good as the constant
you get like in pps z
for example um as you presented it
you said that it's always one over k
which is no
no it's i i didn't mention i tried to
mention
i thought i did mention that it's going
to be always some constant c over
k and this constant c will change
depending on the algorithmic approach
yeah for different algorithms it will be
slightly different constant but it's
always going to be some constant over k
okay yeah and sometimes it's bigger than
one sometimes it's less than one
but asymptotically it's sympathetically
it's like one over k
so i don't want to clutter maybe i'm
confusing people this way but yeah
thank you pavel yes that's a good point
and of course people do care about this
constant and
try to improve it for special cases and
still write papers of getting better
meta-analysis of various algorithms yes
okay so according to my watch it's been
five minutes
all right the chair has spoken
let me let me just say let me just say
one thing
um there's going to be a
gathered town meeting for all of us
at the end of your lecture so i will
post
the link everybody's invited to come in
and
some of us will be there i believe
valentine might also be there
maybe will you will you come to gather
the town
yes yes perfect so okay so i'll post
the link at the end of the of your
lecture so please go ahead
yes yeah i'll try to answer to my sims
question but
somebody ryan bit me to it yeah it's a
deterministic algorithm
um the specification algorithm is
completely deterministic you just
look for for the sunflower
find the best one if it exists and then
you deterministically split
and then keep going yeah so there's no
randomness needed
good okay um
back to the k sat algorithm
um so as i mentioned this theme of
satisfiability is pervasive through
complexity theory
and the sat is the gift that keeps on
giving uh and we're
still studying it and even when we think
we do something else like proving
circuit lower bounds
uh we're still working on algorithms it
turns out
so let me explain to you how that
happens
so to talk about the switching lemma i
need to explain to you a simpler model
than
kcnf model the model of decision trees
okay so i'll draw a picture for you so
decision tree
is is binary tree so let's say you have
want to compute a function some function
f in five variables x one through x five
uh you can do it in this model where in
the node you query a variable and
depending on its value whether it's zero
or one
you keep going on the left branch or on
the right branch of the tree
and so you keep creating variables
labeling the nodes of the branch
and based on the value of the variable
in in your inputs you
keep walking until you reach a leaf and
the leaf is maybe labeled by one
in which case you output yes or accept
or one
or the leaf may be labeled by zero in
which case you output zero or
reject and the natural parameter of this
decision tree
is the depth which is the length of the
longest range
in the tree okay so it's a very nice
very simple model it's much simpler than
kcnfs or
kdnfs because it's very easy to
show that if if i have a depth d
decision tree
then i can convert it into uh dcnf
or ddnf whichever i like
okay so basic idea is that i just gonna
encode each of the branches by
conjunction of literal so for example
here this range that goes to 1
will be encoded by saying not x1 and
not x2 that's what will take me
to this particular leaf
and then i'll do the same thing for
other branches that take me to
decision one and this will give me
disjunction of conjunction of literals
and this will be my dnf in this case and
if i want to do a cnf then i'll just
take the decision tree for the negation
of my function f
by simply swapping zeros and ones and do
the
dnf for that and then do negation again
and
negation of dnf becomes a cnf for my
original
function okay so both d d c and f and d
dnf are very easy to do
okay hopefully this is clear
why do we like decision trees well they
so simple
that um satisfiability is very easy to
answer
if you're given a decision tree well you
just look at the decision tree
and see if you have any leaf labeled by
one if so then you have satisfiability
answered yes right there's a way to get
to the one
by following some range so that will
give you a satisfying assignment
well it will give you not just a
satisfying assignment but
you can also count how many satisfying
assignments there
are and the reason for that
is that different branches of the
decision tree
uh focus on completely disjoint
subsets of assignments that take you to
those three
to those leaves so the assignments which
take me on the left
most range are those which have x ones
set to zero and x two set to zero and
the other three variables
x three x four x five don't matter
so no matter what they are uh and there
are two to the three
eight assignments possible uh all of
those possibilities will be satisfying
assignments
so this range here is responsible for
three to the two to the three satisfying
assignments
and the second range this one here is
responsible
for assignments which start with 0
1 and then have zero for variable x4
but the other two variables are
completely unrestricted
and so you can get another two to the
two
satisfying assignments for the second
range and note that those two branches
talk about completely disjoint sets of
assignments
the reason is like if you take a
particular assignment there will be
unique path in the decision tree you
have to make
so it's not possible that the same
assignment will take you to different
leaves
you have unique branch that this
assignment will follow and that's well
uh that's the reason that this
assignment will go okay so all the
regions that is joined
and moreover you know the size of which
region of assignments that
that take you there by looking at the
length of the path
that took you to that particular leaf so
length of the branch
gives you enough information to count
all possible satisfying assignments
and so that leads you to this following
simple fact that
sharpshot for depth d decision trees
can be solved in time proportional to
the
size of the decision tree which of
course is at most
two to the power the depth of the
decision tree
okay and formula that i mentioned
before sharps up you can count by
looking at
branches labeled by one and doing this
calculation exponential
in n minus the length of the branch
okay so um small depth decision trees
are fantastic
because not only can you answer some but
you can also do
count sat efficiently sharp set
efficiently
how we're going to be using this
intuitively
well given an arbitrary kcnf it's
probably not
going to have a small depth decision
tree
to begin with but we're gonna
try to help it encourage it to become a
small decision tree
by setting some variables to some
constants
uh and we'll do it randomly using the
notion of a random restriction
and the switching lemma that we're going
to be using
is the fact that says that if you take
an arbitrary kc and f and apply
a random restriction meaning that you
set some variables to constant
constants with some parameters of the
distribution
then with very high probability your
kcnf
will become a small depth decision tree
and then once it's simplified like this
it's very easy to
do like satisfiability or even count
satisfiability
problems for for your restricted cnf
of course you need to worry about
different restrictions so you'll see
that you'll basically try
all possible restrictions and
since with high probability they will
make the formula simple
most of those restrictions will make the
formula simple
decision tree and that's you can answer
the
sharpshot question there very easily and
for some rare
occasional cases where your restriction
does not make the formula simple
you have to work hard but that doesn't
happen very often
so all in all you'll save over the brute
force to the end
runtime this way i'll give you more
details now so it's just
trying to give you a preview of what's
coming
so let me explain what random
restrictions are so you have this
two parameters and for the number of
variables in your cnf
and l is for the number of variables
that will be left alone that will be
left
unassigned constants so they will stay
they will survive they will live
you pick a random subset of the
variables so subset s
of indices between 1 and n of size
exactly l
and for each index i outside of s
you'll pick a random bit b sub i and
then your restriction of the variables
x1 through xn
will be defined as follows for each
variable i raw of that variable is going
to be
the same x i if the variable was
left to live it's in the set capital s
and there will be like
l such variables or if the variable is
outside
it will be replaced by constant randomly
chosen 0 1 with probability of 50 50.
okay so after this random restriction
exactly l variables will live and the
rest will be replaced by randomly chosen
constants 0 and 1.
and the switching lemma says that if i
start with a kcnf
and i pick a random restriction r with
appropriately chosen parameter l
then with high probability when i look
at the restriction on my formula phi
under this raw and i and i built a
decision tree from it
which can be done in a straightforward
way in a naive way you can always
try to build decision tree from your cnf
by looking at each clauses in turn
and building decision tree from each one
and
putting them underneath each other so
it's a notion of a canonical decision
tree that you can do constructively
then this decision tree will have small
depth
with very high probability over the
choice of a random restriction rule
okay so that's the statement
informally here's a more formal
statement known as hostas switching
lemma
from around 1987.
it says that for any parameter p between
zero and one
if i start with the kcnf phi
and for any parameter s which will be
the parameter on the depth
the probability over the random
restriction or r raw
that has parameter l the number of
variables that will live
said to be exactly p p times n okay so p
fractional
excuse me so exactly p fraction of
variables will be
surviving so with probability all but
7 pk to the power s the resulting
cnf phi when i apply the restriction
will become a small depth decision tree
the probability that the decision tree
will have depth bigger than s
decays exponentially fast with s
okay so that's the important thing to
remember here
uh bigger than depth s happens with
probability exponentially smaller than s
y exponentially small and s because we
can always choose the parameter p
any way we like and we'll choose it to
be something like 1 over 15 k
so that seventh pk becomes
smaller than one half and so this is
exponential
uh decay in the depth s okay so the
point is that very likely
your decision tree will be small depth
so how do we how are we going to use
that
so here is a sharp casa algorithm
given as input kcnf formula phi
it will be randomized algorithm but it
will be a
zero error algorithm meaning that
it will never make a mistake
but sometimes will not give an answer
actually what we're going to show is
that this algorithm is going to be run
in expected small time
so it will not make a mistake but
sometimes maybe slow
but with high probability it will be
relatively fast it will have time that i
mentioned to the power n times 1 minus
1 over 15k
so what's the algorithm going to do it
will pick a random set s
of size pn notice not a coincidence here
i mean pn is exactly what the switching
lam
was telling us about so you pick a set
of the right size
and you pick p to be sufficiently small
like 1 over 15k again not a coincidence
because that's what the switching lemma
parameters want us to do if you want to
have exponential decay
of having large depth when the formula
is hit with a random restriction
and then we do the following computation
exponential time computation
so we have the set s of live variables
and then we try all possible settings
bits b there are n minus p n variables
that will be fixed
in all possible ways okay so for all
possible way of fixing the remaining
n minus p n variables you look at the
restricted formula phi
where those variables outside of set s
are fixed and the variables in set s
remain free
and then you take your formula phi after
this restriction build a decision tree
from it
in a canonical way and once you have a
decision tree you solve sharpshot
in the way that i described earlier you
look at the branches see how long the
branches
and this will give you the count for
each of the regions corresponding to the
leaves of the decision tree
okay so that's the algorithm
okay
so all of them clear
so obviously the algorithm never makes a
mistake because
it does the exact computation okay
so it's listed assignments into regions
disjoint regions it doesn't overcount
because all the regions are disjoint
and it doesn't miss anything because it
tries all possibilities for this bits b
okay so this is an exact algorithm
we just need to analyze the runtime of
this algorithm so the correctness is
obvious what about
the runtime
and i can analyze the runtime exactly so
i'll i'll give you the complete proof
i'll give you the complete analysis here
it's only a few lines so that's why i
can do it
so let's analyze the expected runtime so
it's going to be a random variable of
the
random choices made by the algorithm the
only random choice is the choice of the
set s
at the very beginning of the algorithm
of this size
p times m and giving this a random
choice
the run time will basically be
proportional to
how many possible assignments you need
to make to the remaining variables
outside of s and you see it's basically
going to be some exponential
in n minus p n and we want to keep it
this way and we want to
we want this to be our final time so
everything else must go away somehow
so you do the summation overall possible
to the n minus pn assignments
and for each one you'll do the sharpshot
computation
for the restricted cnf formula phi where
the restriction comes
as the set s of the variables that stay
alive
and the bits b of that you fix the
remaining variables outside of s2
okay so let's try to analyze how much
this time is going to cost us
but we're going to make some tricks
so instead of thinking of this sum as
the sum
we'll try to convert it into the
expectation
how we can do that well we're just going
to multiply
and divide by to the n minus pn
okay and then
we'll take this part outside
here and the other part one over to the
n minus p n
is like the probability under the
uniform distribution of picking that
one particular b so this summation
after the proper multiplication with the
proper one over to the n minus pm thing
becomes an expectation over all possible
b's
and now we can merge the first
expectation with the second expectation
and just write it as a single
expectation where you pick a random set
s and then you pick a random assignment
b to the variables outside of s
but what does that remind you of
this is exactly the random restriction
raw the way i defined it earlier
you pick a random set and then you
randomly assign variables outside of s
so let's call it what it is a random
restriction raw
that comes from the distribution script
r
with a parameter pm
okay so with a simple trick
uh we converted our expected runtime
to a much nicer expression which has
this huge
bound in the front and the rest is just
some expectation
which talks about the restricted
cnfi under random restriction raw coming
from the distribution
about which we know something we know
something from hosted switching lambda
okay there's there's one more
simplification i did
going from the top line to the second
line
remember what the time of sharp sat for
the decision tree is
so if you're given a decision tree of
certain depth
then to solve sharp set you just need to
go through all the branches of the tree
so the time it takes you to
solve sharpshot for decision tree is
the size of the decision tree which can
be upper bounded by the two to the power
the depth of the decision tree
okay so this time of sharp side of
decision tree is upper bounded by
2 to the power depth of the decision
tree
that you get from phi under the
restriction raw
that makes sense
okay so with simple observations
we made our life so much easier now all
we need to do is to talk about
this expectation of random restrictions
of this exponential quantity to the
depth of the decision tree phi that
you're playing from phi
when you hit it with the random
restriction raw
okay so we'll leave the left
multiplication term as is and the
expectation of
a non-negative integer variable can be
written as the sum
over all t's of the probabilities that
this variable is bigger than or equal to
t okay that's another simple
observation that you can write
expectations of integer valued variables
as the sum of the probabilities or the
probabilities are
of the event that the variable exceeds
some integer
threshold t and you range from t for t
from one to infinity
okay good
so making progress
now this quantity here i want to
talk instead of talking about total
depth
bigger than t i want to talk about depth
big bigger than t
or that bigger than s actually because
remember what has that switching lemma
told us
they gave us it gave us a nice bound
on what what probability is there that
the decision tree has depth bigger than
s and what i have now is something like
totally
depth to the depth of the decision tree
okay so i want to convert to just the
depth of the decision tree so i need to
take like logs on the both sides
of this expression here or put
differently
i want to change my summation from
integers t to powers of two so i want to
go
instead of bigger than or equal to t i
want to go bigger than to the power s
and i want to try all possible s from
like zero to infinity
okay so i want to change from all
integers to just powers of two integers
of course when i do so i miss out
certain integers that were there but not
no longer there because i only focus on
the powers of two
so i need to take that into account and
how many integers do i miss when i go
from two add to the power s
to two to the power s plus one
i miss exactly in the middle i miss
exactly to the s
integers okay so those which i
don't count anymore so i need to
multiply
by this quantity explicitly
and then look at this the same
probability as before
and this way i can go from my summation
over all integers t
to summations overall powers of two
uh with an extra multiplicative factor
inside
okay but that multiplicative factor even
though it's huge to the power s
is not going to bother us because hosta
switching lemma has very strong
exponential decay
and we choose p appropriately so that we
overwhelm this exponential to the s
in the probability that uh the the after
the restriction the depth of our
decision tree
for the c f i becomes bigger than s
what what is going to be uh hosta tells
us it will be
7 pk to the power s which was p
with 4 side so that this quantity will
be 7 15
to the power s okay so we plug in 7
15 in here and we get
2 to the s times 7 15 to the s it's only
14 over 15 to the s
strictly less than one magic
and then the summation of this geometric
series just converges to some
constant constant being 15 in this case
so this whole expression becomes
constant 15 times
to the n to the to the power n times 1
minus 1 over 15k
as promised okay
so that's the whole proof and
the constant you get here is not as good
as you get in some other algorithms
but this is the counting algorithm as
opposed to just satisfiability algorithm
that you get from other approaches
and if you ignore the constant which of
course people
care about and try to analyze the
algorithms very precisely to figure out
what their constant is
in front of the one over k but if you
know that then asymptotically it has the
same runtime as all these other k-state
algorithms
but it gives you more information about
k-star formulas by allowing it to count
in addition
any questions is it is that clear
[Music]
okay so i'm basically
getting towards the end of my talk
uh
okay so paul i was asking a question
uh i guess is it easy to say what the
best constant c is no it's actually
saving ck in the exponent
um yeah no it's not easy for me at least
to say what the best constancy is
i think yeah thank you thank you naveed
it's pi square over six i guess for
general
k there were some improvements for maybe
unique case sat some improvements to
ppsd that were published recently
[Music]
i'm not sure what the exact constant
they get there they get some improvement
yeah from that paper of stock 19 they
get some improvements over the original
tps z
uh but i wouldn't be able to tell you
exactly what the improvement is i know
that
for like case of freesat if you write
your
uh for uh your expression in the
exponent
the base to the power n and the base is
some constant
less than two then the improvement over
p
s z for the case of unique three side is
like in the third digit
uh after the dot decimal dot like one
point blah blah blah
something one uh less than the previous
one
but yeah it's very difficult for me to
say what would be the exponent
c uh pi squared over six is bigger than
one
i think that's pretty clear so ppsz and
other related algorithms can get
savings c over k where c is bigger than
one what i've shown you just now
c over k is for c equal to 1 over 15
which is less than one
okay great
so uh what we've seen is that circuit
lower bound techniques this polynomial
method i mentioned earlier
that shannon williams used to prove
to construct saturn group and i think
they also get sharp sat algorithm in
their paper
it seems like the circuit lower bound
techniques
are a bit more powerful and allow you to
do the counting
not just satisfiability and so you get
set algorithms not just for
excuse me you get set algorithms not
just for the case of
kcnfs but and this was an important line
of research
you also get circuit set algorithms
for various classes of circuits for
which we can prove
circuit lower bounds
so this result that i just told you
about
um switching lemma based uh algorithm
for counting satisfying assignments for
kcnfs
has actually been used in that paper of
imperative methods in patturi
to get counts out algorithms for
ac 0 satisfiability where ac 0
satisfiability is like an extension of
cnf satisfiability where instead of a
simple formula which has
end of oars you have more complicated
formulas which have
ends of ores of ends or ores some
constant depth
and those are more complicated than just
kcnfs
you cannot get a good algorithm for
those things if you try to reduce them
by applying something like cleveland's
reduction
from uh circuits to kcnf formulas
you have a significant blow up as you do
so and then your savings
for kcnf will be irrelevant so you need
to tackle directly the question of
satisfiability for those
more complicated models of computation
like circuits
and it turns out that for those weak
models of circuits for which we can
prove lower bounds
which means that we kind of understand
those models of circuits well enough
to reason about them we also usually can
extract sat algorithms for those circuit
satisfiability questions as well
and so this example of switching lemma
uh is used to get
ac zero constant depth circuits circuit
lower bounds
and then you can do similar things with
other weak models of constant depth
circuits which we can
pro lower bounds for so once you have
circuit lower bounds first circuit class
you get a stat algorithm for this class
usually um but also the other way is
also
true if i have a non-trivial sat
algorithm for some circuit class c
and non-trivial needs to be specified
and
basically it means that you better than
brute force
so you're better than time to the n but
then there's a question of like how much
better
and also for which size of the circuits
so you always fix the input size to be n
but then the circuit size may vary it
can be just polynomial and then
it can be weakly sub-exponential in n
like to the end of the epsilon for
example
so it depends on what kind of exact
circuits that question you're talking
about
and non-trivial can be you do better
than to then by
polynomial factor in the in at the
bottom to the n over poly n
or you do better by sub-exponential
factor electro then
divided by two end of the epsilon so all
those things can be
called non-trivial savings for circuit
side algorithms
and for the right choice of non-trivial
non-trivial
you get this connection um uh due to
ryan williams that says that if i have a
non-trivial stat algorithm for a circuit
class c
then i also get lower bounds for that
circuit class c
okay so it's kind of going in the
opposite direction um
before we set from circuit lower bounds
you get algorithms now we're saying from
that algorithm they get circuit lower
bounds as well
okay so sat algorithms keeps giving and
is connected to circuit lower bounds
in both directions
and actually depending on the
non-trivial like the lower bounds you
get
can be made for a function which lives
in a class
almost np it's non-deterministic
polynomial time so it's like monotonic
time
and to the end to the poly log n
okay so this is the complexity class
another sequence of polynomial time of
course np would be
fantastic
but even quasi-polynomial time functions
in quasi-polynomial time
pre-circular bonds for those is great
and yes vijay again asking me a question
directly
yeah when i when i talk about circuit
lower bounds i do refer to super
polynomial lower bounds in general
of course exponential lower bounds would
be better
and sometimes we can get exponential
lower bounds and again exponentially you
can
have different notions of exponential as
in runtime of set algorithms you can
talk about
strongly exponential or sub-exponential
or weakly exponential
but basically like uh circuit lower
bounds we have for example for constant
depth circuits
have the form uh 2 to the n to the
epsilon
and that's the best we know for constant
depth circuits
we don't have uh to the n
lower bounds even for constant depth
circuits so that would be
the dream and for the results i
mentioned here
the lower bounds you get as a conclusion
from the stat algorithm
usually also of this kind
because uh they cannot really outperform
the lower bounds that we have for those
circuit classes
and you know the techniques we have
don't seem to give us
super strong exponential lower bounds
but yeah that's a very interesting
question yeah the point is that
like we have um different approaches to
proving circuit lower bounds
uh the traditional classical approach
like hosta switching lemma
uh that i mentioned earlier is more like
combinatorial in nature
you you stare down at your model
of computation and you try to understand
its properties
in switching glamos cases the properties
of kcnfs
and okay what property kcnfs have under
random restrictions ah
they simplify nicely okay fantastic this
is the property we're going to use to
show that something like parity
which cannot be simplified no matter how
how hard you hit it with random
restriction remains parity when you
fix some variables to constants
this parity cannot be computed by
constant type circuits so this kind of a
combinatorial
approach which gives you circuit lower
bounds for
functions which are very simple function
like parity for example
functions in polynomial time even in
contrast
this stat algorithm based approach to
lower bounds
can only handle functions pretty high up
there
in space like in normal sequence of
polynomial time or even
non-restrict exponential time or even
higher depending on the quality of site
algorithms we're talking about
but they have different approach they
they really exploit this algorithmic
connection
the better side algorithm you have the
more powerful side algorithm you have
the stronger lower bounds you get and
the lower bounds you start algorithms um
in a very indirect way
that i don't have time to go into
but basically it combines this
combinatorial approaches
sometimes by saying that we understand
the circuit class
well enough to explain it in terms of
this conventional property
and then you use the standard complexity
theory machinery
for uniform tree and computation using
so-called diagonalization arguments
uh old results that come from counter
and from turing
that you can diagonalize against small
time and bigger time
so combining those combinatorics and
uniform complexity results
you get this circuit lower bounce from
sat algorithms
and it's very interesting direction and
surprisingly fruitful
because even for a special case of
circuits
we can show an application of this
approach
to see say that non-distributed
polynomial time
does not have polynomial size constant
depth circuits
where the constant depth circuits allow
to ask
mod 6 for example questions
so you allow mod six gates in addition
to your standards and or
and not gates and proving
a lower bound for this case of constant
depth circuits
with composite modular gates was a big
open question for many years
the combinatorial approaches seem to be
stuck
and the sat approach worked out
fantastically well
and it based on the commaterial
characterization of acc0 that we knew
about
and with some other clever ideas
to push this whole argument through okay
so um that's pretty much all i had to
say
uh for today's uh tutorial um
there's a lot there's a lot of things to
talk about
and uh when i was preparing this uh
these tutorials i had some grandiose
plans in mind like how many things i'll
be able to cover and talk about
because sat is connected to so many
different things
and there are so many interesting
stories out there
that we can talk and talk and talk so i
had really to be
very conservative and like
cut myself in terms of how much i can
cover
but sat will continue to be the
fundamental problem
in complexity theory and we we're going
to be stuck
dancing around sat until maybe one day
we'll understand the complexity of sat
well uh whenever that day comes and
until then we're still going to be
exploring
and covering the properties of sad
connections to other things
and sat will become the central sound
like problem for complexity
for many years to come
i have another question from vijay um
before you take the question let me let
me just thank you very much for this
very beautiful talk
thank you very much so i think we
started already with the discussion
uh so let's continue a little bit people
please ask on the
chat or on meet yourself and you can
also ask
yeah so uh vj is asking uh for sat
algorithm for circuit class what do i
mean
does the algorithm directly deal with
the circuit representation or is it
converted into cnf first
no it's not converted anywhere it's
direct
circuit so you give me an actual circuit
describe the actual circuit with all the
connections with all the gates and all
that
and i will answer the circuit side
directly if i try to convert it anywhere
then i have to introduce new variables
and that will blow up the input size and
then
even if i have relatively good cnf sat
algorithm
uh the savings i'll get there will be
blown away by the
increase in the input size the instant
size that i'll do
during the reduction so that's what i
mentioned that you cannot really
deal with everything by converting it to
k sat
because the quality of k-site algorithms
known today is just not enough to
overcome that blow up
in the instant size so you need to work
directly with instances
as they given so circuit status for
circuits
so i have a good question myself uh
that connecting the two parts the first
two parts of your talk today
so when you told us about the
specification
um well the main result there is that
the number of clauses is not
is not relevant for getting these sub
exponential algorithms
right and then in the second part you
gave a sub export
i mean an algorithm with this running
time where you were using the switching
lemma which
intriguingly doesn't use the number of
closes so the
switch is independent of the number of
clauses so the question is
is this a coincidence or is there a way
to get
for example specification from the
switching level
who could they be connected in some way
yeah
[Music]
um so
actually for yeah i'm not sure
so people have have tried to um
get specification for more general model
like constant ab circuits and i think
it's
it's uh not possible if i remember right
but for in terms of like the number of
um clauses so for this
ac0 satisfiability result of
imp um you actually
generalize the switching lemma to
something
um more which takes into account
not just a single cnf but a whole bunch
of cnfs
and that's kind of like the
specification
thing in the sense that the number of
cnfs
will influence the
overall efficiency of your algorithm and
so
this the classical result is talking
about a single kcnf
but when you have a ac0 circuit then you
can imagine that you have
this constant depth construction and at
the bottom two levels
you have the cnfs hanging off and you
have a whole bunch of them
and you want to analyze the the effect
of the random restriction
not just with respect to a single cnf
but like the whole collection of the
cnfs together
and you want to argue that like a random
restriction will simultaneously
simplify all of them and for that you
need a generalized version of the
switching lemma that was
proved in the paper by palazzo methodist
patturi and
around the same time using the original
proof techniques of hostat johann hostet
also proved a version of that switching
lemma
so we also have like a is complexities
little complexities of switching lemons
now
we have the original switching lambda
then we have this generalized switching
limo which is called multi-switching
lemma
um which is a bit difficult to state so
i i'm not going to state it now
and then of course we have switching
lemmas and proof complexity
that i use to prove great new
improved lower balance for constant
depth formulas
so specification versus switching them
i'm not sure if there's any connection i
wonder if
anybody maybe somebody knows
like russell ryan
or in any case the floor is open for
more questions
so so uh can you hear me thanks again
valentin for a great talk
um so quick question um what if
with regard to the sparsification lama
imagine
if you knew more about the structure
of a class of instances would that
enable you to
somehow further strengthen this llama
like
and in general you know analysis of some
of these
sub-exponential algorithms has been
explored
so for example you know the only
parameters you seem to consider
are the width of the clauses
in addition to the size of the input as
measured in terms of the number of
variables
but what if what if i had other
parameters typically when i
think about it instances obtained from
real world applications
they tend to be highly structured and
they're not
you know they have no resemblance to
the random classes of formulas or uh
that you
consider but by random i mean you
uniformly generated
right random yeah that's an excellent
question like uh
can you have some natural restrictions
on the class of formulas and say
something non-trivial maybe
even more non-trivial than what
specification lemma tells you that's
your question right
yep yeah uh i don't i'm not aware of
anything along those lines again i think
russell is on the line somewhere
uh maybe he knows uh he's the
specification lemma
originator um that would be great and i
know it's connected to other things that
people are
and part of this uh sat for a special
semester will be about of trying to
understand
what makes that algorithms that we have
today work well uh what kind of
properties of instances they exploit
and yeah i think that ties into that
theme of uh
what kind of properties of inter-general
classes of formulas
there are that will lead and we can
explain the success of
sat algorithms or maybe like structural
properties of those
formulas that can be exploited by
backtracking style algorithms
yeah so yeah specification as you see is
very natural kind of backtracking
algorithm analyzed
so it's uh
uh russell has a note specifications
yeah so specification is very general
statement
so it says something for the worst case
so linear density is
the hardest case for the work not just
for average case but for worst case so
it's a more general statement
yeah but i guess the question was like
can you can you make a less general
statement which will take advantage of
some structural properties of your
formulas
rather than saying that it's anything
clause
the number of clauses can be anything
the structure can be anything
you can always do the dpl style
algorithm and reduce it to sparse case
in sub exponential time but can you do
better if you know more
yeah i think
so it looks like some people want to ask
questions orderly but
we should grant them access i don't know
how to do it
maybe jesse are you there
so i think one has to give a panelist
how do you say permission or whatever
it's called
and i don't know how to do it
so there are some more questions on the
chat or uh
the comments i see some comments from
russell in the chat
morgan wants to ask for example but i
don't know how to give him
mohan can you unmute oh okay
are you able to unmute
[Music]
he's not a panelist someone needs to
promote the panelist yeah
don't know i mean i don't have uh
permissions to promote people to
fundraise uh jesse can you do that
yes uh albert i think you do have
permissions uh
how do i do it uh you go to the
attendees list and what's the name
what is the question so you go to the
attendees list
and you click more and then under that
it says promote panelists
okay
latin is here here
more promote to panelists okay
so now it's done
so mohan should be able to speak now
excellent
[Music]
[Music]
parity problem block parity that already
has
that cannot be specified further
[Music]
maybe there are other ways by which you
can explain structure
[Music]
um not really i think
yeah it was difficult here uh i think he
was talking about
specifications i heard the
comment by mohan i think i think mohan
was saying that the
he was in response to my question which
was about structure
and the answer was that structure may or
may not help
it depends on on the setting i think
that's how i understood
mohan's comment
[Music]
yeah charity is like the black charities
are examples
uh
[Music]
right yeah
um yeah parrot is a very hard function
for
cnx so if you have some kind of
block parity function you won't be able
to specify it
a lot because now there isn't around a
small cmf
in case you know it doesn't matter
okay any other questions
naveed has a question crafted
extractors can be used formulas of small
tree width can be solved more easily
um yeah of course
but there's a comment rather than a
question it's not a question yeah
okay so let me post on the chat the
link for gather dot down and we could
move there and continue our
conversations maybe
with the speaker or maybe between us
so let me post it here if i manage
or maybe antonina can you can you put it
because i'm not able to do it
if antonina is around so
let me conclude this uh session today by
thanking again valentin for this
beautiful talk and also
by announcing or encouraging you to look
at the videos if you haven't done it
yet especially valentine also because
he covered many classical topics of
complexity theory
including proximate counting i mean
he was talking about the valiant
vasilani reduction to unique set
which appeared today during the talk
but also this technique of hushing is
also quite relevant because on friday
we're going to hear a talk on
approximate counting in a practical
setting using such solvers
and the methods for that that one
meal will be telling us about are using
these methods of approximate counting
that were developed in in a theoretical
uh framework first with hashing and then
they become into a practical
technology so it's really worth looking
at this uh
these videos that valentine did and i
encourage you to do it
so thank you very much everybody very
much thank you very much albert
and i think now gather the town is
already in chat
bye
i